il est le plus ancien de france datant
de 1947 et désormais rénover le centre
de déminage interdépartemental de
versailles située à marly le roi a été
inaugurée par bernard cazeneuve jeudi
dernier un centre qui sera en première
ligne pendant l'euro puisque ses 46
agents agissent sur onze départements
notre mission principale actuellement
c'est la lutte antiterroriste on va
s'assurer que
tous ces endroits vont être sécurisés
pleinement et ensuite ce sera les
interventions comme on fait tous les
jours dans le cadre de la lutte
antiterroriste sur les onze suspects
découverts par les particuliers ou dans
sur le réseau ferré après démonstration
du matériel
le ministre a multiplié les annonces
dans le cadre du projet déminage 2020 1
million 600 mille euros seront consacrés
d'ici à 2017 à la sécurisation des
centres 300000 euros pour la
modernisation des systèmes d'information
et 720 milles pour les équipements j'ai
également pris la décision de vous
autoriser à porter une arme
dans le cadre de vos missions comme vos
collègues policiers
vous intervenez très souvent sur des
situations complexes dans des
circonstances difficiles souvent hostile
et tout comme vous pouvez être la cible
de la haine et de la violence au simple
motif que vous porter l'uniforme et que
par là même vous incarnez la force
publique que vous incarnez l'état de
droit dans les mois à venir cinq mineurs
viendront renforcer les effectifs de ce
centre et de nouveaux travaux sont
programmés d'ici fin 2010 est les 320
agents répartis sur les 23 centres du
territoire effectué plus de douze mille
interventions en moyenne chaque année en
france